who thought that there was a time in
Margaret Abhi's life when you that we do
not afford toilet paper you just didn't
feel that was a good thing to spend
money I mean no it wasn't you know I
wasn't flush at the time but I was also
working all the time and I was busy I
know exactly what you're referring to I
know exactly what picture of furniture
because it's the first time I got packed
and it was really embarrassing
I just been my friend was in New York in
town she was going back to Australia and
she was like oh I've got some like this
still do you want the rest of that my
makeup or whatever I'm not gonna pack it
I'll say no no I'm good a sigh oh I've
got no toilet paper at home though and I
haven't had time to stop and I was like
oh
took the toilet paper because I didn't
have time to go to the show otherwise I
would have the financial thing and I
took her bag which was a Ralph Lauren
bag but I didn't realize at a time and
when I walked out of the building
suddenly like all these cameras like and
I was like oh my god someone famous is
around I was like who is it and then my
cousin's like I think they're taking
photos of you I was like oh god this is
worse time to get photographed I've just
got stolen
toilet paper it was I got that picture
and it is genius knowing that in the bag
is just a lot of stolen toilet paper
shopping in
I mean seriously when you buy from Ralph
Lauren I didn't cause Daniel you've a
similar thing on set don't you that
still sucks yeah but I've got pattern I
don't want to be cool okay this they
spoiled it
so it's may ruin it con okay okay go
so I do I do like a four-day run so the
basin you come in with your socks yeah
and then they give you socks and then
like you just don't change it and you
take your socks home and I keep doing
that for every four days and a fifth day
I stop doing it because then I get then
I won't do it for two weeks so you steal
starts with every day for two weeks
Ford I'd steal socks for four days then
have a two week break shopping for socks
is a waste of life also caution
designers have better taste in socks
than me so they're always nice these are
stolen
[Music]
you